hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel so in today's video I've
completely click baited you guys because
I said I was going to be talking about
SQL versus nosql databases however if
you've watched kind of the first
iteration of my system design videos
you'll know that I really don't like
those terms the reason being that just
kind of generalizing about a database
based on its query language is stupid
there are plenty of SQL databases that
do act a certain way but there are many
other implementations of databases that
use SQL that act very differently and
the same goes for databases that don't
use SQL as their query language hence
why I don't like the term SQL and nosql
what I prefer to use instead is
relational and non-relational databases
so let's go ahead and talk about those
discuss the differences and then move on
to subsequent videos where we can look
at actual real world examples of
databases okay so we're going to start
by talking about relational databases
what are they now you definitely may
think of a database like MySQL or
postgres when I'm talking about
something like relational databases and
if you do you are correct however MySQL
and postgres have other stuff going on
between them other than the fact that
they just are relational databases which
is why I'm going to keep this video
pretty General and then make dedicated
videos for each type of database so what
is a relational database well basically
the whole point of these are we have a
bunch of different tables where each
table represents one type of data model
so let's imagine I'm talking about
trains and stations because trains and
stations have relationships between them
so as you can see in the trains table
I've got red line Blue Line pink line
and the stations I've got Broadway
Yankee Stadium and your mom because I
can't resist the low-hanging fruit of
making a your mom is getting trained
joke so then of course what aspect of
this involves relationships well we know
that a train can be at multiple stations
and a station can have many trains going
to it and so as a result what we have
here is actually a many-to-many
relationship and so that is exemplified
by the train stations table and what
we're using are something called
foreign ideas sorry for the siren that's
just Chicago for you so we have foreign
IDs and what the those basically say for
us
are it creates the relationships between
two rows of two different tables or they
could even be in the same table if we
really wanted to but basically this row
right here is saying uh train with
ID one at station
id1 so it's saying that the red line
stops at Broadway and what this is
called is called normalized Data because
for each piece of data that we want to
represent we just put it in our tables
once and then using foreign Keys we can
establish relationships between them in
SQL we could leverage something like the
join keyword in order to basically take
one of these things like the red line
and then merge it with keys one two and
three based on the fact that these guys
are lined up over here but again we're
not worried about the query languages
here we're more so worried about how
data is actually organized so what are
the downsides of relational databases
well mainly they just have poor data
locality so what do I mean by that well
let's imagine that all three of these
tables were in one place realistically
those tables are not going to be lined
up to one another on disk you know they
could be here and here and here and so
when I'm actually seeking I have to go
to a bunch of different places on my
hard drive but this is a distributed
systems focus and even more so a more
catastrophic case would be there on
physically different nodes in our
cluster
so what that means is we might have to
end up using distributed transactions in
order to perform rights let's say I
wanted to add a new train station and
you know we know that certain trades go
to it now I have to write to both the
stations table and the train stations
table which are on different computers
in the same right and that means that I
would have to use something like two
phase commit which is slow even if we're
not performing rights if I simply want
to perform a join now I have to read
from the trains table the stations table
and the train stations table and as a
result of that my reads are going to
multiple different systems that's just a
lot of extra latency and so distributed
reads are also going to be slow
so what can we do to actually go ahead
and mitigate the cost of having poor
data locality well we could organize our
data differently so that we have better
data locality and the way we would do
that is with a non-relational database
so traditionally most nosql databases
are non-relational however that's not
always the case which again is why I
don't love the term nosql but if you see
it that's probably what they're talking
about so instead of using normalized
data no sqlized databases use
denormalized data which means that we're
keeping our data effectively in
something called records just think of
it as a key value store or something
similar to that
and as opposed to you know having
relationships where one row can
explicitly reference another we actually
keep all of the data that we need in
every single record so imagine that the
keys were the train names now all of a
sudden the values are all of the
stations so you can see your mom is
repeated for the red line blue line and
Brown Line because it is a station that
all three of those trains go to so now
we do have better data locality but
obviously that has to come at a cost
right we have repeat data and so what
are the trade-offs of something like
this well for starters we do avoid cross
partition reads right because let's say
I wanted to know all of the stations
that the red line stops at it's all
stored right together which is great
however this comes at a big cost which
is that if I wanted to say hey your mom
is out of commission for the week I
don't know maybe uh she's been having
too many trains then we're going to have
to remove that from three places and
that right there might be a distributed
transaction in and of itself because all
three of those deletes need to go
through so it's important to note that
rights can be extremely complicated if
you have to modify the same thing in
multiple places because the data is
denormalized instead of normalized
and then additionally let's imagine that
this contained a bunch of extra data
right here depending on the type of
non-relational database it's possible
that you may have to load all of that
other data instead of just the portion
that you want whereas in SQL you can
typically just grab the rows that you
want and any other relationships that
you need you would explicitly use the
join keyword to fetch them the point is
that you may have a little bit less
flexibility in terms of how much data
you have to load and send over the
network but I think there are actually
certain databases that will let you make
that a little bit more granular so you
can send a bit less
so what's our conclusion here again I
don't want to basically assume any
particular type of locking or database
index type usage or replication schemas
or anything along those lines because
the truth is there are many many
different types of relational databases
there are many many different types of
non-relational databases so even though
I could go ahead and say like oh you
know generally relational databases use
B trees that's not completely true and
it would be misleading to say such a
thing that's why we're going to go
through specific databases so what is
the general case where you actually want
to be using non-relational databases
versus relational ones well when there's
non-relational data if your data is all
disjoint right and I can keep it as
separate messages or separate records
within a database table and they don't
really relate to one another at all
think about like separate I don't know
Facebook posts I don't really ever have
a relationship from one Facebook post to
another Facebook post they're completely
separate different users post them at
different times and things like that and
so they're good to just be their own
tables at the same time if I wanted to
basically represent a relationship in my
data let's say we've got a bunch of
different books
right and each book could be pointing to
a separate author
author one or author two that's a good
example where you may want to use a
relational database because we have data
that is naturally well represented by
relationships so of course when choosing
a database you need to really think
clearly about how the organization of
your data is going to look and then
making that decision between a
relational or a non-relational database
is oftentimes going to be the first
decision that you need to make anyways
guys hope you enjoyed this video I will
see you in the next one and uh yeah have
a good week